I'm just a mouth on legs
[Applause]
[Music]
classic Doctor Who review and my patreon
supporters this month have helped me
narrow down a fifth doctor story yes
joining the patron allows you to vote
and help decide what classic ones I'm
gonna review getting the plug in there
earlier I am pushing it a little harder
I uh I was gonna say I apologize but I
don't I could use the help but in any
case so fifth doctor and this time I
gave I didn't necessarily stack the deck
in terms of like only giving really good
options for a fifth doctor story which I
have done in a couple of businesses
lately because I kind of had a run of
not great classic stories so I I did
start only like pushing for better
options this one I did give a mix of
stories that are well-regarded for the
fifth doctor and ones not so well
regarded they picked one of the best
regarded stories for Peter Davison's
tenure as the doctor and that is Earth
shock which I had seen before it had
been quite a while since I saw it though
and parched because it was so well
regarded it's also one of the ones that
I saw when I first started watching
classic who and it's definitely
something that's worth revisiting
because when I first started watching
classic who I had a hard time getting
into a lot of it even some of the fairly
decent stuff just cuz I wasn't quite a
climate into the head space of classic
who yet now that I feel like I get it
better I I was due to give this one
another shot
so yeah I'm debating at what point you
get into stuff that would be considered
spoilery and how far into this four-part
story do I consider stuff to be spoilers
because it's it's it's hard to talk
about this one because it is so well
known for very specific very spoilery
reasons I'll let you know what I've got
across
into outright spoilers but this is the
period of time where we have the doctor
traveling with three companions he has
Nyssa Tegan and everyone's favorite
Adric and things start out and the
doctor is this doctor is moody I think
part of why I have a hard time
connecting with Davison as the doctor is
I have a hard time following his mood
shifts I mean many of the doctors can be
moody but I can at least like see what
throws them in one mood or another a bit
better
often times I feel like Davison will
just get into a mood and get snippy with
everybody just because and like I'm not
even sure why half the time and that's
one of the things that throws me off and
I've said this before with other Davison
stories which is that his doctor is
surprisingly quick to violence like this
is the I think the third Davison story
I've seen where he has picked up and
fired a gun it's weird like how
frequently and readily he does that at
least it's weird to me and you know
maybe if I was more used to him as the
doctor I could go into it get into it a
bit more I'm not saying that yo it's
forbidden for the doctor to do that but
obviously the doctor very rarely does
that kind of thing so when a doctor who
I feel like I don't get is also doing
something that strikes me as undock
Trish yeah it kind of throws me off a
bit but he's his performance in his
rapport with pretty much all the
characters guests and and companions is
pretty solid and that works well he's
delivering the lines pretty well like I
said I I am having a hard time sort of
following his good mood I guess a little
bit at times that I'm still got that
here but it's not as severe here as I
have sometimes found it to be it is
still a little
I think you know maybe it's just the
fact that how cranky he is at times is
just so at odds with sort of the
softness of his face and sometimes you
know that kind of juxtaposition works I
think with him part of the reason it
doesn't is it just makes him seem
petulant it doesn't quite have the
quality that at least I felt Matt Smith
had with Matt Smith had which was that
he was very he was a young man but he
felt like a much older one
Davison's doctor doesn't feel like an
older man to me so when he behaves in a
way that admittedly all doctors prior to
him and most of the ones after him
behaved when he would get Moody and
irritated it just comes off as a bit
more bratty because of how baby-faced he
is maybe that's part of it I don't know
I need to start to stop talking about
Davison particularly because I keep
waiting to warm to his doctor and it
keeps not happening like even though I
see the supposedly really good stories I
don't know
so as far as the others let's talk
general setup of the TARDIS at this time
as I said there's three companions and
there should not have been like they
could not come up with a good stuff for
all three of these commands to be doing
it was really clear that it was
overcrowded boy wonder if if that was a
lesson that future show runners would
learn but I mean like in the tail end of
the show they actually basically split
the party because you've got Adric with
the doctor you've got Tegan with this
sort of military little squad and then
you've got Nyssa back on the TARDIS
we'd be because she had to be somewhere
and do something I'm not sure she
actually does anything of note other
than read readouts on the console but
yet it they really did have a hard time
finding stuff for all three of them to
do and you can really feel the weight of
that
and as far as the story goes ie I'm
gonna have to okay well I'm gonna say I
was gonna say I have to get in something
that's kind of a spoiler or at least it
would have been at the time this
originally aired but isn't it really but
I'm still gonna hold off on that a
little bit longer so we've got this
initial setup with the doctor being in a
mood just landing in a cave system in I
on earth in in the future and happening
to be there at that time is an
archaeological team and kind of a
military squad who are and the military
squad is there because there's only one
surviving member of the archaeological
team they're trying to figure out what
the heck happened and the doctor sort of
stumbled into this now kind of what's
interesting is the initial setup is
fairly mysterious there's a couple of
blatant things then that I'm like okay
well here's how it's gonna grow so like
there's there's basically a sort of a
readout that one of the soldiers has on
the surface that shows him you know
where everybody is relatively in the
cave system but it's said early on you
know it's it's cute for you know living
things and mammalian living things so
immediately you're like oh well
obviously there's gonna be some sort of
thing down there that isn't what they're
designed to pick up but it actually
opens up a lot of possibilities and
honestly and and this is worth saying
because this this first episode
especially is structured in a way that
the reveal at the end of the first
episode of who of what villains are
behind everything is treated as a
surprise and everything up to that is
sort of like who are we dealing with so
that's actually kind of cool and if you
now I mean most people at this point
probably know I don't know what the
boxart is like on it like if you pick up
the DVD or somebody I'm pretty sure it
shows who the villains are but even
beyond that you know its reputation
speaks for itself at this point but if
you don't know that first episode
my first guess would have honestly been
the Silurians you're under the earth at
a paleontological site they're finding
dinosaurs it does it only picks up
mammals the Silurians our reptilian
based you know it that would have been
my first guess and it's kind of cool the
twist of kind of a spoiler now because
it's at the end of the first episode but
it is also only the first episode so the
Cybermen which i think was their first
return since the Tom Baker episode I
forget which one it was and I actually
rather liked this design on the Cybermen
there's a little touch where they've got
sort of you know well you know they're
they're the metallic looking whole thing
you know fairly standard in the general
shape but the the mouth covering on the
bottom jaw is semi-transparent you can
see the human jaw moving behind that now
normally I consider that a fault be like
I can see the performer under the under
the costume but in this case I actually
think it really works and because for me
at least the the Cybermen are scariest
when you get reminded that is whatever
is left of a human being inside there
and I think that's a big part of why the
what we've had for most of modern era
Cybermen hasn't really worked for me
quite as well because they just look
like robots like the story has to go out
of its way to remind you that there's
human being in there just do the
functionally they just feel like robots
but sort of seeing that is is a semi
constant reminder of like oh yeah that's
right that's that was once a person who
and it gives you that little that little
creep factor which is good I mean that's
a good thing for the Cybermen to have
and sort of and there's little homage as
well if you got Simon kind of breaking
through like clear plastic I'm like
that's straight out of tomb of the
Cybermen they're busting out of stuff
and yeah so there's some cool little
Limoges like that it's it's fun watching
the cyberleader sort of
look back at earlier incarnations of the
doctor we get some clips of the first
the second the fourth so I guess the
third nut third doctor never ran into
the Cybermen that I guess I assumed they
would have showed that if he had and
there's also and this is a minor thing
but this is a touch that I really
appreciate given some stuff that drives
me crazy with especially modern
storytelling these days which is that
the doctor sort of they they stumble
across a bomb a bomb that with potential
planetary levels fought levels of
Fallout down in this cave so now we're
getting into like second episode stuff
at this point whether or not you
consider that spoilers I don't know like
overall this is good this is one of the
better fifth doctor stories certainly
that I've seen I still have like
niggling things about it but I'm gonna
kind of get into that and it'll get more
spoilery as I go from here so there you
go so he so the doctor obviously
disables this bomb and then tracks the
signal for where the bomb was coming
from onto a spaceship and the doctor and
the team then go up there and then deal
with the Cybermen there so part of what
I like about this is that the the
Cybermen the bomb was supposed to
detonate and the the doctor foiled that
plan and then what goes on on the ship
is the contingency plan it's even
flat-out called that by the cyber leader
and I like that as a detail because one
of the like modern stories what it would
have been was the doctor was supposed to
find the bomb and they expected him to
discernment and it's all part of this
grandeur plan that doesn't make sense
because why would you have being
defeated as part of your plan
but like this whole notion of the
villains were planning all of this whole
long is so ingrained in modern day
storytelling and so many writers and
directors or whatever think it's clever
and it's not it almost never makes sense
I much prefer villains who have backup
plans as opposed to I always knew this
would have like well
no I wasn't counting on that but you
know I have a plan B I'm gonna do that
now so I like that and then I definitely
appreciate that certainly in the wake of
a lot of stuff that I see today that
drives me absolutely up the wall so what
else we got we got we got fairly decent
supporting cast
there's surprising gender diversity in
the support gases it feels uh feels very
agenda-driven that I mean the captain
the ship's a woman first officers a
woman there's a sergeant and the
military as a woman I'm being facetious
at this point and I'll stop but like you
kind of get what I'm saying you did you
choose to watch these things through
that lens look it applies to everything
but in in any case there is like kind of
a cool mix of characters and what I like
about the human characters is that they
are not you know that they are a mix of
intelligences they're mix of agendas
because you've got you know the the guy
who's heading up sort of the military
squad who you know he's coming at it
from that militaristic minds that which
tends to clash with how the doctor likes
to approach things and it does a little
bit I mean he's kind of fixed in his
ways
you've got the captain of the ship who
is not unintelligent but is obviously
very motivated by profit because this is
a freighter and if they don't get back
to Earth by a certain time they don't
get a bonus and she's making just bad
decisions in the interest of preserving
the bonus there is one of her officers
who is a trader who comes across as
incredibly by-the-book and like and part
of his betrayal is a bitterness towards
the captain it's actually surprisingly
well rounded and they're all pretty well
performed as well I like that this isn't
a case of all the humans are the
straiten are on the straight and narrow
and the Cybermen are the villains like
no the humans you know we've got a
traitor
the humans missed but even the quote
unquote good humans are flawed they're
you know human so that's cool I mean I
mentioned missus she's kind of useless
and this one Tegan has a few nice
moments um plus she's got some some nice
lines but let's finally get to the big
spoiler the big spoiler thing if you
don't know what's going on in this
stories this is your last warning before
I start to get into this let's talk
about Adric so first of all I would say
that regardless of what you think about
Adric specifically it felt very clear
that three people in the three
companions and interest is too many and
somebody needed to go and it's kind of
funny watching it and knowing that
Adric dies by the end of this that like
at the start he's saying I want to go
back home I'll plot you know the the
course to take me to my alternate
dimension that I come from and part of
me even though like later on there's a
bit of dialogue like d-did you actually
want to go back he's like no just wanted
to make a point
but when he first started being all in
system I'm like oh my god it's like he's
going I've only got two weeks until
retirement no wonder he died and
actually while I've seen a couple of
other Adric stories not a ton he's
actually not bad in this he's a little
whiny but you definitely is his
frustration with the doctor specifically
does not come across as excessively
childish because the doctor is actually
kind of being a jerk especially towards
him and he's got validity to his to his
issues and how the doctor is treating
him so and that sort of helps with the
poignancy because if he was as annoying
here as he can be in other episodes then
you know nobody would care when he died
we just all be dancing and going woo
which I'm sure some people still were
anyways but there
is I actually really like the the
closing moment you know right before he
dies this idea of he's on the freighter
that is effectively gonna be the meteor
that kills the dinosaurs which is in and
of itself kind of a cool idea I kind of
like that as a whole notion and he's
doing all this stuff to try and stop the
impact and then the cyber men ensure
that he won't be able to and it's going
to crash in the distant past and he just
kind of looks at the approaching earth
that he's about to crash into it goes
I'll never know if I was right because
he was doing all these calculations and
he was so certain that he had it figured
out what he had to do to be able to take
control the ship back but then it got
that but then the everything got
disabled he never had the chance to see
if he was right and there's something
that is slightly childish about that
that adds to a bit to the tragedy and I
don't mean childish in like he's
throwing a tantrum or pitching a fit but
just something like I was in the middle
of this and I don't even get to finish
like that sense of the it just has that
tone of that's not fair to it which I
mean some people never grow out of the
concept of trying to find you know I'm
trying to forcing everything to be
quote-unquote fair but you know that
that is very much mentality that is
driven from the mind driven in the mind
of a child it's supposed to be fair this
isn't fair and I think that adds to the
to the sadness of it in addition to sort
of the suddenness of it I do think like
for me the the closing credits for the
last episode being with no music and
just showing his broken little badge
thing is a little cheesy but I mean I
get why they did it especially
considering that like companions dying
not really
that happened much if at all did it did
a companion died before Adric I don't
think so
like lots of people always died and
these I don't think a companion had died
prior to that though so you know I can't
fault them too much for taking a little
bit of momentous moment with it even
though it's a little cheesy
I think that's that's about it I
Adric was no great character again I
haven't seen a ton with him but what
I've seen of him what mood I can
remember of the stories I've seen that
he is in because by and large I don't
even remember him what I do remember is
him being kind of whiny and annoying
like many child characters are and these
things like you know he's Wesley Crusher
why why to suck bike shows never learn
why do they keep sticking kids into
these things and they're always like
uber intelligent bratty kids too why
anyways so it was I I do feel that this
this story and also for Adric as a
character this is a probably better
send-off than the character deserved but
you know it does work I feel like at the
end of the day I wasn't blown away by
this because well why is it cuz of
Davison I'm still I'm still trying to
find a hook in with this guy I just it
things don't quite click into place with
me and the more I think about I think it
is I think it might be the age I think
it might be how young he is but not just
how young he looks how young he feels in
his performance because I can think of
like time crash the the short thing that
that he appeared in with Tennant and he
honestly works way better for me in that
because he's an you know he's visibly
older and he feels older and it works
way better he's kind of worked better
for me and Big Finish to because he has
the feel of age behind him his
what what in previous doctors came
across like the arrogance of age and
experience and knowledge with Davison
really feels like the impetuousness of
arrogant youth which I don't know it
just doesn't quite work for me with the
doctor it's the wrong kind of arrogance
but he still he still plays the part you
know decently and he's got a pretty good
script but digest I know other people do
like Davison I just have yet to find a
story where he really clicks for me I
don't know
still waiting it's still pretty good
story though it's a solid four parter
and a pretty good send-off for I'm not
very good companion so there we go
earth shock what did you think about it
whatever thoughts are drop something
down the comments let's talk about a
whole bunch of links as well I mentioned
the patreon I'll leave it at that but
there's links to other stuff to check it
out if you feel like it if you don't
that's okay cuz at the end of the day
you are the council and I'm just one of
the meetings and until next time this
council is jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]